also vilimsky forderte weitere massive
hilfe von der nato gleichzeitig
versuchen die ukraine sich selbst zu
helfen wir den später hält er ist in
chemnitz die einer industriestadt mit
270.000 einwohner zwischen kiew und der
polnischen grenze peter und sag uns was
tue dort gerade erlebt
wir sind hier an einem sogenannten
außenposten vor der stadt hier ist ein
bürgerbataillon hat sich hier
eingegraben quasi das ist so einer der
verteidigungslinien wir können jetzt
nicht sagen wo es ist aber eine der
verteidigungslinien die eben die stadt
vor großen vor angreifenden tanzer neben
schützen soll ich will das mal kurz
erklären wir sehen hier rechts von mir
auch schon arbeiter die fällen hier alle
bäume und das hat einen hintergrund wir
sehen hinten das feld man will ein
freies schussfeld haben eine freie
schussbahn dass man genau sieht wo eben
dann panzer oder einheiten an rücken das
ist hier so eine typische stellung da
kommen wir gleich noch zu hier sind
molotow cocktails und hier sind
sandsäcke auf getönt wir gehen mal
weiter
hier sind die hier sind checkpoints hier
wird dann zugemacht hier ist ganz
emotional eigentlich hier haben die
kinder der soldaten und der bürgerwehr
fotos oder bilder gemalt für ihre eltern
für die väter die eigentlich jetzt die
ganze zeit hier in den stellung sein
müssen und wein und schauen mal wie sie
eigentlich tag und nacht leben müssen
und da sieht nicht schön aus eigentlich
also da möchte man nicht tauschen wird
bekommen wir hier reinkommen durch
das hier ist so eine typische stellung
dir schlafen die kämpfer auf wir können
wir umschwenken dass wir viel gegessen
auch tag und nacht
schlafen sie auch hier dann manchmal
bleibt große chemie könnte auch das
sprechen dort ja ich kann mir ein
bisschen durchbrechen war hier nur nur
essen und sich wärmen
schlafen hier nicht
unsere leute nicht schlafen weil nachts
sind sie dann hier dann ist man nachts
hier in der stellung und hat sich dann
ein bisschen kann sich ein bisschen
wärme hier am feuer weg immer weiter
wir haben hier
eine der wenigen verteidigungsmittel das
sieht jetzt ein bisschen provisorisch
aus aber hier sehen wir molotow
cocktails und die sind sehr effektiv
auch valentina ist ja valentina ist eine
kämpferin wenn ich das mal so sagen darf
die im mai dann schon gekämpft hat
valentina wie können sie sich gegen
russen wehren können sie das mal
erzählen peter übersetzt
glück hat die super mama do salahi
jonathan mann soll oder die cocktail
dann in die hände nehmen und sofort auf
die panzer dann rausschmeißen und die
breiten adern hinter die entferner dann
und dann da kommt auch dann die gemeinde
zu schieben versucht ford kommt die
gemeinde die die ist ja auch dann von
ihnen alarm bereit
cocktails
wie immer auf der lauer als auch wenn
die panzer hatte zum vorschein kommen
dann dann werden sie auch das bekommen
und das wird allen drauf geschmissen und
sofort an alles abgebrannt das ist eine
supermacht eine hochtechnisierte armee
hat sie keine angst zu sterben mit zwei
euro molotow-cocktails maximal gegen
millionen panzer
da habe ich keine angst zu sterben also
für die ukraine für das volk für die
freiheit nehm ich bin bereit zu sterben
das hört man hier von vielen kämpfern
von vielen bürgerbataillon und wir gehen
noch mal weiter hier
was natürlich das große problem ist hier
ich möchte euch mal mitnehmen
ist natürlich dass die große angst
besteht dass sabotage einheiten hier
einfallen was wir in china schon gesehen
haben menschen die getarnt sind als
zivilisten russen die dann als
zivilisten in die städte reingehen und
versuchen gefährdete in oder
infrastruktur zu sabotieren wir können
mal hier schauen das sind dann hier
diese typischen bunkeranlagen und hier
wird dann auch kontrolliert kofferraum
koffer werden kontrolliert und zu gucken
ob irgendwas mitgenommen wird also das
sieht alles extrem einfach aus und
behält und wirklich sehr ja ich will
nicht sagen
gefährlich also wenn man sich vorstellt
dass eine hochgerüstete hochtechnisierte
armee hier so ein checkpoint so ein
stützpunkt überfällt überrollt dann kann
man ahnen was sich hier abspielt aber
trotzdem sind die leute die kämpfer hier
die bürger extrem motiviert und wir
haben ja auch in den anderen städten
gesehen dass diese art von partizan
kampf der russischen armee extrem
zusätze und wirklich nadelstich mäßig
auch verlustreich dort arbeiten kann bzw
den russen dort schaden zuzufügen also
das ist das vertrauen was die menschen
hier haben aber natürlich die große
angst wenn diese riesige macht ihr
einfällt dass es eben hier zu sehr
schweren und verlustreichen kämpfen
kommen kann jeder das sind unfassbare
bilder die du unter ein kameramann und
dann übersetzer uns hier zeigen die
wirklich all das symbolisieren über dass
er die ganze zeit geredet hat ich weiß
nicht ob es möglich ist ob er nochmal zu
diesem unterstand gehen können denn nur
uns am anfang gezeigt dass wo wir die
bilder geschenkt wir haben diese
kinderzeichnungen wir gehen noch
gleichzeitig daneben sehen wir wie eine
waffe aus der kleinen leute dabei
herausschaut das ist ja für mich das
symbolbild dieses tages kannst du uns
das noch mal zeigen
das ist in der tat ein symbolbild das
zeigt eben auch die motivation und auch
die
kampfkraft dieser menschen die ihr sind
gemeinsam halt als als gemeinde wir
haben mit valentina gesprochen sie hat
sie ist eine vielzahl waren kommandeurin
von drei bataillonen die gemeinsam mit
der armee eben auch versuchen hier
widerstand zu leisten und das ist genau
das was eben die russen fürchten es ist
eine mischung aus irrsinnigen
patriotismus aus kampfgeist
zusammengesetzt von bürgern mit im
einklang mit der armee was ebenso eine
so ein gegner komplett unberechenbar
macht das heißt da geht es nicht nach
normalen militärischen gesetzen sondern
da werden wie in partisan art
nadelstiche gesetzt und das ist für die
russische armee halt nicht auszurechnen
das ist ein nicht planbarer kampf und
das wissen sie und das macht eben diese
menschen hier so stark und eben auch so
siegesgewiss
vielen vielen dank für diese
beeindruckende reporter